今日はい誰かが料理が上手くなりたい男初めて超です結局ねぇ
料理できる男って持ってるんですよ
も出てなけれどもが本当は何もできないんでまずは簡単だけども美味しいものから
作ろうと思ったんですけども食べ物食べ僕の技術的に無理なこともわかってるんで
飲み物をまず作ってみようかなと思いました
皆さんが世界でいちばんおいしい飲み物何か知ってますか
[音楽]
はいその通りでマンゴーをらしいです皆さんアンゴラせた目でもありますか i も
いざ2ってなんかインド風のカレー屋さんとか
ここっちでもこいつってたっけなぁこうこいつにもってますねココイチにも全然降って
ます南郷ラシックのあるんですけどもこれ実はですね
世界一美味しい飲み物なんですね嬉しが世界中日のはもう舌
ついて毎回カレー屋さんに行くのもちょっともったいないんで自分のて作れねえかと
思ってちょっと孫らしいを作るレシピを調べてみました
用意するものはこちらマンゴーの缶詰牛乳ブルーマップ
ブルガリアじゃなくてもいいですプレーンヨーグルト蜂蜜です
多分作り方は分かりませんよろしくお願い致しますと5材料集めはなんとかなるぞって
考えて帰ってきちゃ
作れるかの不安とのなんか調べたんですよね自分で
いやマンゴーラッシーめちゃくちゃおいしいって本当にみるきーとフルーティーの合体
というかもう一文字一緒にミキサーいるんだ
ん
ほっときますミキサーなかったでさんにこれがあったので多分これも方美紀かですこれ
でウィンって混ぜれば多分できると思うのでやっていきましょう
下院では作っていきましょうまず凪せればいいやまずマンゴーの間を切りましょうね
はい難しいなあ俺にそんな技術あるかと言われる動画なんけどね関係たらちょっと
かっこいいね
4ユーザーやはできるできるジャックにこれあげ
れないと院で検閲の顔逆に見てみたいですよ
やはり
取っただけでも大 hi-fi ない bang on シロップ
シロップを待つ切りますどういうことを切るってか水を切ればいいないって言って
水切ります
[音楽]
切ってきましたマンゴーのスプーンにがミキサーにマンゴーヨーグルト牛乳砂糖を入れ
て混ぜます
えっもうできるんだねこれはこんな感じ混ぜていきますまあまあで全部打った矢部
戻します怪獣みたい入りましたヨーグルトいれば適切な容量がたいじゃないかもわから
ないで感じ入れましょう
こんなもんでどうすると牛乳売れます
あってっぽい濃い濃い濃い声砂糖を入れます
うざい蜂蜜
持ってちょっと雨具スンギはっきりちゃんとおめじょ依存しんですね
なあ桜井できますちょっと現像だとば着くと黒いんですけどもうこれを今から混ぜて
美味しいマン暮らしをつくっていきましょう
いきます
dee
んがっ
お前が混ざらなあかん
[音楽]
[拍手]
ファイトやゲマズ終わりましたこれで完全なのかちょっとわからないんですけど多分
大丈夫だと思いますでは飲んでみましょう
勝利の美酒に乾杯
を言っ
まず味クソまずいぞなんでなんでなんでば感じもひょっとしたら中マンゴーラスって氷
入ってるイメージあるからコーディネート
コード8時になるのかも知れませんだかバナナジュース生まれたかぐるっとしてまずい
んですけど交流映像美味しくなるんで氷といった意味きたしてみましょう
開いてきました綺麗に氷が混ざったんでこれ事も神のマンゴーラッシーと言っても過言
じゃありませんでは
いただきます
[音楽]
なんでああ
なんでなく何生具材生臭へタージマハールで食べたマンゴーラッシーを持って
美味しかった足道時過ぎたかッてると牛乳を立てば持ってんだこれ割合の問題かしらね
と z ありますよ実際
あああああ
黒夕食を買うわー
御野場へ王ドラシューテレ家がおかしいから
いただきます12 u ました方もちょっとませんあっても気がする
me
行グルトなネタがヨーグルトはたなかった気がしますヨーグルト2分においしくなると
い気がする
比率で多分味が規模に広島いただきます
[音楽]
甘くなくなった味が良いがなくなってきましたでもた殺到を足せばいいんですね
佐藤足せば良いよ本当に美味しくなるのです
[音楽]
だそうなんか来た気がするん
ん美味しい蒸し
mango だし美味しいですまずい圧倒的まずさ
想像絶するマンゴーラッシーの松谷初めは混乱シーター
彼はこうも思ってしまったのだマンゴーらしって本当に美味しいのか
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
1回けどね本当に
おいいいんだなん
バッハ
はぴじゃねえよ